it's now on the harry maguire story
breaking news for you and we understand
from the course in cyros
that harry maguire has been handed a
prison sentence of 21 months and 10 days
but this will be suspended because it is
a first offense
and his charges were misdemeanors if you
are just
tuning in to this story an update that
in the last hour harry maguire of course
the captain
of manchester united football team and a
player in the england squad today
selected for the nation's league squad
against iceland and denmark
was found guilty along with his brother
and another defendant
christopher sharman of three charges
of aggravated assault of resisting
arrest and
repeated attempts of bribery of an
official this follows on
from a barbaral on the party island of
mykonos
at the weekend his defense had argued
quite strongly this morning
in court that they didn't feel they'd
been given enough time to prepare for
this trial given that it is
uh only tuesday um but
uh the chief prosecutor who spoke to us
in sky news a little bit earlier said
that if he had apologized
uh they wouldn't have had to have taken
this action they said it was
unsportsmanlike behavior
when a sportsman and a role model you
are a sportsman and a role model you
have a duty to say
sorry and he said that they were totally
appalled
by the lack of apology of course harry
maguire's defense had been all along
that he hadn't known
that the police officers were in fact
police officers because they were in
plain clothes
but i'm just going to read you now the
statement from manchester united
and it says that harry maguire continues
to
assert his innocence
they also say a request for a case
for the case to be adjourned had been
subsequently denied
on this basis along with substantial
body of evidence
refuting the charges harry maguire's
legal team will now appeal the verdict
to allow a full
and fair hearing at a later date so that
is an update this evening from
manchester united football club
interesting that they are speaking on
behalf of him because of course
harry maguire himself not being in court
there today his father
attending but remember this is being
held in a greek court being held
in the greek language this update then
harry maguire being sentenced to 21
months
in prison which will be suspended
because it is a first offense and those
charges were just misdemeanors but of
course
manchester united this evening
confirming they will appeal it